[Applaudissements]
longtemps j'ai refusé le temps je
refusais d'accepter que le temps passe
si vite
il y a un certain temps gt gt cette
petite fille déguisée en pierrot puis
cet ado crado et puis vélo boulot dodo
il y à 51 jours j'étais assise à cette
table du café le poliveau les yeux
cernés écrivant sur des feuilles
brouillon ces mêmes mots que je dis
maintenant
et aujourd'hui je suis ici avec vous ils
traquent sa foule vertige comme le temps
passe vite
non et à tous ces moments j'étais
quelqu'un d'autre j'avais dépensé des
problèmes des joies des attentes qui ont
maintenant disparu ou changer mais
chaque chose vécu a laissé des traces
plus ou moins consciente et souvent nous
sommes guidés par ses expériences
si par exemple je suis tombé par terre
en mangeant ce pain au chocolat divin de
la boulangerie ardéchoise le bûcheron je
ne fais pas de pub
alors j'y retourne mais je suis déçu le
miracle est passé ou alors par exemple
la peur les séparent à un accident de
voiture qui m'empêcherait de conduire à
nouveau
sauf que je crois profondément à la
liberté et je crois que nous en laisse
peu d espace de liberté mais il existe
encore un endroit où nous pouvons être
vraiment libres dans notre action
à chaque instant et je souhaite que mon
action ne soit pas conditionnée par ces
traces du passé et à agir ainsi en toute
liberté
et puis et puis un jour j'ai arrêté le
temps oui oui mais pas comme on mettrait
pause dans un film james bond bondissant
duo du golden bridge soudain immobilisé
non au contraire c'est dans le mouvement
que j'ai arrêté le temps et c'est à
travers deux expérience que j'aimerais
réfléchir avec vous à cette formule si
peu mathématiques ce vertige face à la
vitesse du temps qui passe
je les trouve particulièrement quand je
pense aux deux années pendant lesquelles
j'ai vécu en inde elles me semblent
appartenir à un autre monde
c'est presque le cas à un autre espace
temps complètement irréel et je me
surprends avoir des souvenirs très
précis très forts et nombreux de cette
période
des instants du quotidien qui me
reviennent souvent à l'esprit qui
surgissent de manière inattendue et je
crois que c'est parce que dans les deux
grandes villes où j'ai vécu delhi et
pune les cinq sens sont sans cesse
sollicités
il y a
il y à l'odeur du jasmin et des paccots
à free les klaxons des rich cho et leur
chauffeur qui s'engueulent les cris des
perruches et le moteur des 125 les
couleurs des saris et des pull pailleté
des hommes
en hiver il y a
le vert de la végétation après la
mousson un vert très fort qui prend aux
yeux
il y a le goût âpre d'un chahut de rue
qui a bouilli toute la journée et le jus
épices et des gaules gap et qui explose
dans la bouche le corps et stimuler tout
le temps les sens mis en éveil et c'est
comme si cette explosion sensorielle
était venu fixer des instants prix à vif
comme du magma pris par l'air qui
devient rock dans l'instant ce qui m'a
vraiment éveillé et émerveillé en inde
c'est l'apprentissage de trois arcs
classiques et folkloriques juste pour le
plaisir de prononcer leur nom
il s'agissait du thé du coup tout du
coup dit adam et du kathak en kata qu il
y a le tas de cale les pieds qui claque
le sol les jack car les tours rapides et
les moudre à
en kata qui lie à une danse que j'adore
faire c'est le ganesh vent ne va pas
dans le ganesh bandana la danseuse est
tour à tour la narratrice qui décrit le
dieu ganesha
ses sautes d'humeur
avec ces femmes la danseuse est aussi
le priant qui se fou qui fait la poujade
danser le ganesh bandana me met dans un
état très particulier et cet état je les
retrouvais à d'autres occasions à
d'autres instants pour celui-ci
d'instants je vais vous parler de ma
grand père à l'entrée de son appartement
il y avait un petit meuble noire où elle
mettait son courrier elle avait posé là
un poulain en porcelaine cabré à la robe
isabelle je me souviens de ce jour où
j'étais rentré de l'école très grognon
elle avait pris le poulain danse et
demain ses mains qu'elle avait si douce
avec des grosses veines bleues t elle a
pris le poulain elle m'a dit regarde
regarde ce poulain comme il a la fougue
écoute tu entends est ce que tu entends
comme il n' y est bien il est ni pour
toi pour que tu retrouves la fougue
c'est un des souvenirs racontés dans le
spectacle intitulé quand l'adverbe pas
la ville dans ce spectacle deux soeurs
ouvre les cartons de leur grand mère qui
vient de mourir
on entend leur réaction dans un
enregistrement audio
à chaque objet surgissent de nouveaux
souvenirs des instants partagés avec
leur mamie je suis en fond de scène de
profils à genoux devant une table noire
et il ya un carton à droite je déballe
ses objets une caméra en direct film mes
mains qui déballent il y à un tulle
transparent à l'avant-scène sur ce tulle
mes mains sont projetés agrandi zoomer
en général avant de jouer j'ai le trac
beaucoup mais pour le spectacle quand
l'adverbe pas la ville je suis plein
d'un calme que je ne connais pas et dès
le premier instant du spectacle un état
étrangement veille
je crois que les mots calme paix
sérénité état méditatif ne décrivent pas
vraiment ni précisément cet état à part
il s'agit d'autre chose
en tout cas lorsque je joue dans camp
que je danse le ganesh bandana j'oublie
le temps
je suis dans cette sensation que le
temps a cessé d'exister je me sens hors
du temps sa part est sûrement un peu
mystique dit comme ça mais c'est une
vraie sensation physique pas du tout
intellectuel ou analysait après coup
c'est c'est un vrai état d'être
aujourd'hui on nous incite beaucoup à
être présent vivre l'instant mais je
pense que ça ne peut pas marcher
justement parce qu'à partir du moment où
l'on veut où l'on se force à être
présents on n'y est pas on est dans un
décalage entre ce qui est et ce que l'on
veut c'est le même effort que dans la
concentration quand on se concentre on
se force à être attentifs
ça se voit d'ailleurs souvent sur le
visage je préfère la tension qui se fait
sans effort dans la détente
la tension est un éveil ouvert vous là
par exemple vous pouvez être attentive
et attentif à ce bruit là à la sensation
des accoudoirs sous vos doigts attentif
à l'odeur de votre voisine ou de votre
voisin l'odeur floral de sa
transpiration attentif à l'éclat des
projecteurs attentif à votre humeur
peut-être taché par la dispute de cet
après midi ou peut être coloré par
l'instant tendres devant le film d'hier
soir attentif aux bruits de ma voix qui
vous endort un peu attentif
à deviner l'animal qui est sur mes
boucles d'oreilles et vous faites bien
on a beaucoup à apprendre des animaux
ils sont sans cesse hors du temps eux
sans cesse dans cet état d'être de
l'instant voyez ce loup quand il est à
l'affût en attente d'une proie chacun de
ses mouvements et danse avec un e mais
aussi danse avec un a
c'est merveilleux pour les acteurs
d'observer les animaux et les insectes
bouger du scarabée aux cachalots et donc
dans cet état d'être
cet état que je retrouve dans le
spectacle quand l'adverbe pas la ville
et dans le ganesh bandana dans cet état
singulier je deviens animal comme une
louve à l'affût et cette étape surgir à
paraître parce que je suis attentive de
toute ma personne en ce qu'elle est
corps esprit et coeur dans le spectacle
quand l'adverbe mon corps est attentif
assis sur les genoux j'étire mon dos à
la verticale pour être bien ancrée et
être précises dans mes gestes
tout comme dans les rues de delhi mais
sens sont sollicités
je suis dans la sensation du papier que
je déballe différent pour chaque objet
il y à du papier kraft du papier journal
du papier nappe
je suis sensible à la texture de chaque
objet à comment je le touche le petit
poulain fougueuse je le caresse du bout
des doigts la boîte à coquillages
contenu mystérieux jeu louvre goulûment
je suis connecté au public
je sens et j'entends sa présence et son
attention
j'écoute l'enregistrement audio pour
synchroniser mes gestes avec le texte
mon esprit est alors alerte vif mon
coeur est attentive je veux dire mes
émotions les émotions qui émerge des
souvenirs racontés je dois aller vivre
dans mon corps sur mon visage est aussi
dans mes mains comme si vraiment je
redécouvrais dans l'instant des objets
surgi d'un passé lointain et donc dans
le spectacle quand comme dans le ganesh
bandana je suis dans une attention
multiples une attention du dedans et du
dehors et de ce qui sépare les deux ma
peau à travers le toucher notamment une
attention ouverte poreuse et j'ai alors
la sensation d'être tel le loup à
l'affût hors du temps d'arrêter le temps
vous pourriez me dire est ce que c'est
bien d'arrêter le temps dans le
mouvement
et bien je n'en sais rien
peut-être que je n'en sais rien
justement parce qu'à cet instant où je
suis hors du temps où le temps n'existe
plus il n'y a pas de distance prise par
la pensée il n'y a pas d' analyses
possibles
je ne sais pas si ce que je vis est bien
mal améliorable mal rythmé jolie
maladroit exagéré toutes ces notions que
le temps fait exister qui s'inscrivent
grâce à une durée non il n'y a que
l'instant bien saillant je suis dans
l'action
et alors à cet instant sur gitans - un
silence un espace
et à partir de cet espace silence de cet
espace qui n'est pas centré dedans ou
dehors cet espace qui n'a pas de limites
qui n'a pas de frontières à partir de
cet espace ouvert s'ouvre un champ de
possibles l'inattendu peut surgir
passées et futures ne viennent plus
conditionner le présent il n'existe plus
de croyance fondée sur ce qui a été vécu
dans le passé
c'est chose donnée par la mémoire qui
par expérience font naître des attentes
désespoir et donc possiblement des
frustrations des déceptions non cela
n'existe plus
passées et futures ne viennent plus
conditionnée l'instant est alors oui
dans ce nouvel espace créé s'ouvre un
univers de possibles dans ce nouvel
espace créé je peux c'est ma liberté à
plein
soyons des louves et des loups à l'affût
libre
[Applaudissements]